[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes tnt locale tout de suite voici
les titres de l'actualité
le procès des attentats du 13 novembre
2015 s'est ouvert à paris cette semaine
thibault et sa femme étaient au bataclan
ce soir là ils n'ont rien oublié de
cette nuit d'horreur leurs témoignages
avec télé 78 dans un instant
l'épidémie de kobe de 19 à contrat le
corps médical a provoqué certains
accouchements de manière prématurée pour
sauver des mamans en détresse
respiratoire aux antilles atv martinique
notre partenaire sur place nous en
parlera dans un instant cela ressemble à
du cannabis mais sans les effets
psychotropes profitant d'un flou
juridique
les magasins proposent du cbb il se
développe partout en france ils ont
trouvé où vous verrez leurs
consommateurs enfin sans attendre les
premières neiges l'équipe de france 2
par à ce qui a pu remonter sur les
planches grâce au tapis roulant où le
verrez dans ce journal et puis en forme
d'hommage en fin de journal j'ai eu la
chance de bien connaître le témoignage
de jean paul belmondo qui m'avait parlé
de son fils paul belmondo
du stade de france au bataclan passant
par les terrasses des cafés du 11e
arrondissement le 13 novembre 2015 130
personnes avaient trouvé la mort et 430
avaient été blessées dans ce qui reste
les attentats les plus meurtriers que la
france ait connu au moment où s'ouvre ce
procès hors norme prévue pour durer neuf
mois thibault a accepté de revenir sur
cette nuit d'horreur au bataclan un
témoignage poignant recueillis par les
équipes de tv 78
130 morts 1800 parties civiles 20
accusés le procès des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 a débuté à paris ce 8
septembre à midi un procès attendu six
ans après les faits pour clore le volet
judiciaire de cette affaire mais aussi
redouter un contexte un peu pesant ça
entre nos esprits la presse ne parle que
de cela je sais que les avocats des
parties civiles travaillent en
collaboration pour être efficace
pertinent et
je crois que le dossier qui a été
présenté à qui va être présenté à la
cour d'assises de la cour d'assises
spéciale est plutôt béton trois attaques
perpétrés simultanément au bataclan au
stade de france et aux abords des
terrasses parisiennes
thibault yvelinois étaient venus
assister au concert de rock avec sa
femme ce soir du 13 novembre 2015 il se
souvient les fameux bruit de pétard que
comme beaucoup de personnes m'ont
rapporté et
donc je suis rattrapé mon épouse et nous
sommes allongées par terre
et un moment j'ai relevé la tête pour et
la salle était allumée et j'ai vu au
niveau du par un homme un jeune homme
qui tirait sur les personnes qui étaient
au sol et c'est là que j'ai compris que
si on restait là on n'allait sans doute
pas on allait se faire tuer c'était
certain et si on essayait de partir ben
peut-être qu'on allait recevoir une
balle mais au mont doré c'est peut-être
qu'on aurait aussi la chance de sortir
de l'ordre le couple arrive à rejoindre
les loges une jeune femme creuserait
alors un trou dans le faux plafond d'un
cabinet de toilette endroit par où ils
s'échapperont ils resteront trois heures
immobile dans les combles avant d'être
secouru par le raid le raid nous prépare
nous organiser pour sortir et quitter a
quitté le bataclan en envoyant moins
possible ce qui est voilà on sort en
file indienne en regardant par terre
mais la vision périphérique il faut à
l'effet qu'on capte quand même
désinformation et c'est le chaos absolu
le chaos est total il décore absolument
partout en aujourd'hui thibault fait
partie de l'association 13 ans 15 qui
soutient les victimes du 13 novembre il
s'est porté partie civile pour le procès
selon lui on ne passe pas à autre chose
mais il faut avancer on passera jamais à
autre chose c'est déjà par respect pour
les personnes qui ne sont pas sortis de
là parce qu'il ya une culpabilité très
très forte nous on a eu la chance de
sortir de là sans être blessé sans
perdre un proche mais il ya quand même
80 90 personnes qui sont mortes
au bataclan le procès devrait durer neuf
mois pour un verdict en mai 2022 une web
radio dédiée uniquement aux parties
civiles victimes ne pouvant être
présentes a été mise en place pour
suivre le procès à distance
si la situation s'améliore en martinique
face à l'épidémie de kobe de 19 le chu
de martinique tire la sonnette d'alarmé
face à la multiplication de naissance
prématurée car de plus en plus de femmes
enceintes sont contaminés lors de cette
quatrième vague actuellement cinq bébés
sont pris en charge à la maison
familiale de l'enfance regardez ce
reportage de tom gagne ou pour vyas atv
martinique nos correspondants sur place
ce jeune couple a échappé au pire il ya
quinze jours muriel alors enceinte de
six mois a développé une forme grave
ducobu 19 elle était en détresse
respiratoire
la terne quand elle m'a vu m'a dit mais
madame vous êtes en difficulté
respiratoire pour vous vous ne venez pas
bien et elle m'a envoyé faire un scanner
pulmonaire et l'appareil de demandes de
de gonfler les poumons etc de la
rénovation du contre-jour pouvait rien
faire j'ai fait comme un poisson qui
était en deux lots pour la sauver les
médecins ont dû anticiper la naissance
du bébé ils ont fait une césarienne est
le maître pédiatre qui s'occupe de
l'année
on va devoir sortir l'enfant c'est
gérald qui aurait transmis le virus à sa
femme après de longs jours passés dans
la peur et l'incertitude
l'homme s'en veut de ne pas s'être fait
vacciner tout le monde parle du coup
vite mais quand on est au coeur de
l'action quand votre vie tout votre lit
s'écrase dans un claquement de doigts
c'est pas le moment de dire je vais me
faire vacciner parce que si j'aime été
vaccinés avant mon épouse ne pas
attraper la coved des cas comme celui ci
il y en a de plus en plus lors de cette
quatrième vague si le prématuré de
muriel et gérald est sorti d'affaires
d'autres sont toujours en soins
intensifs
actuellement cinq prématuré qu'ovide
sont prises en charge à la maison de la
femme et de l'enfant le personnel se
montre très attentif à leur cas si la
prématurité est courant en martinique
celle induite par le comique 19 en
revanche est inédite certains nouveaux
nés en grande fragilité doivent même
séjourné en réanimation cette cause là
on n'avait jamais eu elle est arrivé
brutalement avec beaucoup beaucoup de
deux mamans qui ont souffert de ça est
donc sacré un afflux important de bv 4
prématurés ont déjà été envoyées dans
l'hexagone pour soulager le service de
réanimation mais les médecins redoutent
une prochaine vague de nouveaux nés
contaminée dans les prochains jours
parce sanitaire vous le savez c'est à
partir du 15 décembre que les personnels
des établissements et services
sanitaires et médico sociaux devront
être vaccinés d'au moins une dose en
haute garonne vous allez le voir ils
sont une quinzaine mercredi dernier à
s'être lancé dans une marche de soutien
à anne lise pena cette éducatrice
spécialisée est opposé au pass
sanitaires et à l'obligation de
vaccination est là pour protester entamé
une grève de la faim il ya dix jours ces
soutiens dénoncent une forme de passage
en force du gouvernement
je suis soignante donc je vois le
système de santé se dégrader je vois
qu'on nous a adulé il ya un an et demi
et que maintenant bon ben on est
totalement ignorée et que surtout on
risque de perdre notre travail je trouve
que c'est quand même très extrême mais
s'il faut ça pour se faire entendre oui
parce que là il n'y a qu'une version des
faits je trouve ça très très dommage
regardez ce reportage un garagiste
obligés de refuser des clients par
manque de salariés
depuis deux ans le ver en d'un garage
spécialisé dans les poids lourds à
narbonne rêve d'embauché pour s'agrandir
il multiplie sans succès la publication
d'annoncés via pôle emploi et sur les
réseaux sociaux en occitanie vous allez
le voir cet établissement propose
pourtant de passer le bac pro
maintenance des véhicules de transport
routier mais le nombre de places est
compté alexis martinez a mis les mains
dans le cambouis pour v occitanie
regarder
ce gérant d'un garage spécialisé dans
les poids lourds à narbonne rêve
d'embauché pour s'agrandir mais
impossible depuis deux ans il multiplie
les annonces via pôle emploi les réseaux
sociaux pourtant personne ne postulent
je veux pouvoir répondre aux besoins de
la clientèle s'est toujours refusée
l'autre c'est dur pour ans l'artisan de
dire non je peux pas pourtant le métier
attire sur cet établissement d'occitanie
proposant le bac pro maintenance des
véhicules de transport routier celui de
toulouse du segalini a reçu cette année
114 candidatures pour seulement 20
places au nos formations sont saturés on
a on a que du public je le disais sous
différents statuts sont les apprentis
année scolaire dans toutes nos
formations sont pleines pour répondre
davantage à la demande il faudrait qu'on
puisse développer notre cas pas cette
formation des offres de formation et
pour ça il faudrait déjà que comme vous
la percevez derrière vous on puisse
élargir les espaces de travail car dans
cet atelier l'espace est petit pour
accueillir les camions les professeurs
et les élèves comme julie étudiante dans
l'établissement qui souhaitent devenir
chauffeuse routière et ce bagage en
mécanique s'avère indispensable pour ces
projets il ya des débouchés que ce soit
dans la mécanique ou dans la dans le
transport mais c'est vrai que les
entreprises de transport aime bien que
lanson employés et déjà fait de la
mécanique parce qu'ils savent très bien
qu'on sera attention camions et que au
bruit on saura s'il ya quelque chose qui
raoult qui va pas des formations qui
doivent donc s'adapter en capacité
d'accueil car avec la hausse du nombre
de camions sur les routes chaque année
le métier de mécanicien poids lourds est
de plus en plus recherchés je vous
l'annoncé dans les titres le bund et
boutiques de cbd cela ressemble à du
cannabis cela à l'odeur du cannabis mais
ça n'est pas du cannabis cbd le cannabis
violent issus du chanvre n'a pas
d'effets stupéfiants du tout mais promet
de réduire le stress et anxiété à nantes
pornic saint nazaire guérande une
quinzaine de boutiques en commercialise
les consommateurs sont de plus en plus
nombreux et les contrôles de police
aussi car un certain flou juridique
persiste même si l'état français
envisage d'interdire la vente de fleurs
de ses bd reportage à consommer avec
modération réalisé par anaïs d'aînés
pour télénantes nos confrères sur place
dans cette boutique le cbd se veut
thérapeutiques sous forme d'huile de
tisanes de chocolat et de fleurs vendues
entre 6 et 9 euros le gramme j'adore
quand les clients viennent ici mais on
dirait de la vraie mais c'est la même
plante c'est celle là c'est la vraie
simplement il n'y a pas de y'a pas
simplement les collectifs de thc le thc
la molécule psychoactifs du cannabis
dans le cbd elle est présente à 0,2 pour
cent seulement il ya beaucoup de
boutiques qui vont jouer en fait sur
l'image de cannabis pour vendre leurs
produits mais qui n'auront pas forcément
derrière le conseil expertise puisque la
fleur c'est pas quelque chose qu'on va
conseiller de fumer quand on fume un
joint aux breuleux 60 à 80% des
molécules actives dans sept autres
boutiques du centre ville justement le
vendeur conseil de fumée les fleurs et
les variétés vendu s'appelle amnesia mr
nice des noms bien connus de ceux qui
consomment du cannabis récréatif toutes
ses boutiques se fournissent à
l'étranger italie suisse autriche car le
droit français est très floue en matière
de cbd a priori si on s'en tient au
droit français une fois de plus on ne
peut pas en vendre on ne peut pas en
vendre et on ne peut pas non plus en
exploiter simplement
la réalité du terrain c'est que les
fleurs se vendent dans certaines villes
on trouve ces fleurs sans difficulté
dans d'autres contraire ces fleurs sont
saisies et les les commerçants qui en
feront le négoce sont font l'objet de
procédures judiciaires compliqué c'est
ce qui est arrivé à ce producteur et
vendeur de fleurs installé dans le
finistère la police judiciaire de brest
est intervenu dans nos locaux ils ont
procédé à une perquisition pour
vérifiez si nous avions des stupéfiants
en magasin
ils ont prélevé 30 kg de matière
végétale
qui n'était ni plus ni moins que du
chanvre et ils ont considéré que c'était
de la marijuana le chef d'accusation ces
trafics de stupéfiants or on est des
commerçants on a aujourd'hui un
laboratoire on est façonnée on travaille
qu'un pharmacien en industrie lors d'un
contrôle de police impossible de faire
la différence entre une fleur de cbd une
fleur de cannabis il faut analyser
l'herbe saisie si le droit français ne
s'assouplit pas rapidement ses affaires
viendront submergé encore un peu plus
les tribunaux français nous nous rendons
maintenant dans ce grand jt des
territoires en nouvelles aquitaine où le
début des vendanges dans le bordelais a
démarré avec les blancs modération
toujours mais en toute légalité cette
fois ci c'est parti pour les vendanges
en gironde le premier vignoble de france
par la taille a commencé il ya quelques
jours la récolte des raisins blancs
notamment dans l'appellation
pessac-léognan la fameuse cette période
de vendanges devraient s'étaler jusqu'à
mi octobre si le temps se décide enfin à
être clément il faut dire que la météo a
donné cette année du fil à retordre aux
viticulteurs girondins je vous laisse
apprécier le reportage de télé7 à
bordeaux la chaîne du groupe sud ouest
franck poireau
ils sont une quarantaine de vendangeurs
à couper ce jeudi les premières grappes
de raisin blanc du château carbonnieux
de mémoire de viticulteurs il y à bien
longtemps qu un millésime avait été si
compliqué les équipes de cette propriété
viticole de léognan se sont battus
depuis des mois pour le voir aboutir il
ya d'abord eu les chais les printanier
au mois d'avril puis un été maussade où
l'appui la chaleur se sont alternés cela
favoriser une pression forte des
maladies sur la vigne a été avril mai
juin juillet avec beaucoup de travail
pour entretenir les sols pour protéger
la vie trouver tous les travaux en verre
et finalement les efforts ont payé et
n'a quasiment pas perdu de récoltes dans
les blancs et un petit peu dans les
rouges donc oui ça paye les efforts ont
payé mais on a une part de chance la
vendange des raisins blancs devraient
s'étaler sur les trois prochaines
semaines dans cette propriété viticole
puis viendra le temps de ramasser les
premiers raisins rouges les merlots tout
d'abord dans la dernière dizaine du mois
de septembre en revanche pour les
cabernets sauvignons beaucoup plus
tardif le calendrier est encore
incertain leurs récoltes devraient
commencer au mois d'octobre si la météo
il me lucie aujourd'hui j'ai une grande
incertitude du climat de la météo furent
va connaître dans le mois dans le mois
et demi à venir si on est derrière
saison on peut faire un très bon
millésime les viticulteurs appellent de
leurs voeux à mois de septembre et
octobre relativement sec pour parfaire
ce millésime 2000 21 qui leur a donné du
fil à retordre les vendanges viennent
donc de commencer ce 2 septembre dans le
vignoble bordelais elles le sont mais
précoces et tardives
si le millésime 2000 et 21 était
capricieux il marque un certain retour à
la normale en termes de dates de récolte
par rapport à ces dernières années
c'est le père et ses fils thierry
guillaume gars tu fais c'est leur nom
s'apprête à sillonner la piste cyclable
qui longe le trait de côte entre roscoff
dans le finistère et dunkerque dans le
nord une aventure sportive et humaine
pour les ambassadeurs du vélo maritime
qui les mènera dans un premier temps
jusqu'au mont saint michel mathilde
quemeneur les accompagner à
l'entraînement pour tébéo la chaîne du
groupe le télégramme sur place
parti tôt roscoff père est fier se sont
lancé un défi aller à vélo jusqu'au mont
saint michel ils vont rouler sur une
partie de la ville aux maritimes c'est
un nouveau circuit cyclable qui relie
roscoff à dunkerque je suis tombé sur
facebook sera une info de la vélo
maritime qui cherchait des ambassadeurs
monfils se lançant dans la vidéo et la
photographie je lui ai dit que je lui ai
balancé le sujet en lui disant ah bah
tiens ça peut intéresser il a regardé
puis m'a dit ok mais sur le fait les
deux donc c'est comme ça qu'on est parti
durant leur périple ils ont aussi décidé
de profiter des vieux gréements sur la
côte nord et de partager leurs
découvertes bah pour moi là mon coup de
coeur c'était vraiment aujourd'hui
c'était la route de la falaise je crois
si je dis pas de bêtises et c'est juste
magnifique avec les saints le rayon de
soleil qui filtrent à travers les nuages
et à l'eau turquoise d'autres
ambassadeurs ont réalisé des portraits
vidéos des personnes rencontrées sur
leur chemin d'autres des podcasts au
total cinq projets ont été retenus sur
les 300 candidatures
c'était énorme on s'attendait à recevoir
une trentaine de candidatures dont
l'itinéraire se fait connaître et puis
nous moi je travaille pour un comité du
seigneur justement qui mène plein
d'action promotion pour le valoriser
d'autres ambassadeurs seront sûrement
recherché pour l'année 2022 en attendant
vous pouvez découvrir ce circuit sur la
vélo maritime point fr
tout à fait autre chose le bureau des
accompagnateurs en montagne de gérardmer
dans les vosges proposé il ya peu sur
les crêtes une sortie à la découverte du
chamois le ruminant ce fait plutôt rare
mais l'un d'entre eux n'a pas pu
résister à l'appel des appareils photos
une vraie star des randonneurs ravis de
cette rencontre en ont rendu compte et
en grande forme thierry las on a suivi
la piste du chamois pour vos télévisions
regarder
ce mercredi en fin d'après midi maxime
accompagnateurs en montagne emmène une
dizaine de randonneurs sur les crêtes
vosgiennes la météo y est en effet on ne
peut plus idéal pour l'observation du
chamois et en effet on ne tarde pas on
apercevoir un mais il est beaucoup trop
loin pour le zoom de notre caméra et sur
le moment avouons le c'est un peu
décevant mais à quelques centaines de
mètres plus loin regardez qui s'invite à
la fête
pas vraiment farouche ce mal d'une
quarantaine de kilos qui va faire durer
le plaisir d'ailleurs il se laisser
photographier sous tous les angles le
seul prédateur qu'il a c'est le loup et
le lynx il n'a pas beaucoup sur le
massif
dont on peut le voir plutôt sereinement
pourrait presque le caresser par moment
faut surtout pas le faire les zones de
prédilection de l'animal sont ces
cirques glaciaires il y est en effet
parfaitement adapté il a des dessins
poutre et l'adapter pour pour tenir sur
les rochers la glace il a une très
grosse casse thoracique un très gros
coeur il a beaucoup plus de globules
rouges que l'être humain donc toutes ces
caractéristiques font auxerre l'animal
qui veut monter descendre dans les
cirques glaciaires très facilement le
chamois vite entre 15 et 20 ans pour les
plus vieux et la période des naissances
a lieu fin mai début juin bien
qu'appartenant à la famille des bovidés
l'animal on le voit est bien plus proche
de la chèvre de montagne car il est de
la sous famille des caprine et le
ruminant a été introduit dans le massif
en 1956 précisément 11 chamois du
feldberg en allemagne et aujourd'hui on
en compte un millier une population qui
doit être régulée on régule le chamois
l'instant il ya trop de consanguinité
les chasseurs tuent le chamois dans
chaque année et aujourd'hui on en prend
ici pour introduire dans d'autres
endroits dans d'autres massifs de france
ou même d'ailleurs cet été la météo a eu
raison de certaines sorties proposées
par le bureau montagne de gérardmer mes
paroles d'accompagnateur à chaque fois
le chamois était au rendez vous quant à
notre invité surprise il est reparti là
c'est les photos vers d'autres cieux
retour au japon où tout juste auréolé de
54 médailles à tokyo les équipes de
france paralympique prépa maintenant les
jeux d'hiver qui se dérouleront toujours
en asie à pékin l'équipe de france de
ski handisport a donc attaqué sa
préparation physique sans perdre de
temps par un stage sur une piste
artificielle qui procure des sensations
assez proche des conditions naturelles
est réel luca ruch l'a testé pour nous
et pour 8 mont blanc notre chaîne
partenaire sur place
glissé sur la neige en plein mois d'août
ainsi croirait presque c'est bien sûr
une piste artificielle à pacy que
l'équipe de france de ski handisport
débute l'entraînement de sa saison
hivernale principalement physique
l'objectif est aussi de retrouver des
sensations sur les skis vous fait de
revenir un peu sur les tapis comme ça
glisse et ça nous permet en fait de de
travailler un petit peu la préparation
physique mais une préparation physique
qui va être spécifique ou ce qui est un
petit peu parce qu'on va retrouver quand
même la gestuelle globale du ski alpin
dorénavant l'équipe de france handisport
réalise ici un deux stages par an des
entraînements spécifiques nécessaires au
perfectionnement des athlètes ça fait
partie de notre préparation moi je
connaissais pas ça avant a vendu avant
d'intégrer l'équipe et c'est un petit
plus si tu vois que
je progresse sur les skis et je
progresse ici aussi sur le tapis on a
des catégories de la concurrence qui
arrive aussi il ya aujourd'hui un réel
niveau sportif sur les skis on en dit
aussi et donc du coup pour aller gagner
les centièmes une seconde qu'il nous
faut mais il faut pousser un petit peu
la barre faut travailler des choses
différentes responsables et coach au
sein de la structure depuis ses débuts
denis souhaite apporter tous les
bénéfices de la technologie aux sportifs
de haut niveau le ressenti la travail
technique c'est tout est accentué c'est
un laboratoire d'analysé ya le miroir il
ya le ressenti la personne ses films et
on peut vraiment prendre le temps de
décortiquer la préparation des athlètes
handisport se poursuivra par un retour à
la compétition décembre avant de
s'envoler en février 2022 ricains là où
les prochains jeux paralympiques
s'ouvrir ou
sans transition maintenant le musée des
24 heures du mans fête ses 60 ans et 130
ans d'histoire mémorable de course
automobile pour l'occasion la collection
offre aux visiteurs la possibilité de
découvrir la totalité des modèles toyota
ayant participé d'ailleurs à l'épreuve
mythique un reportage de marveaux bianco
pour lm tv sarthe nos partenaires au
mans
avant la crise sanitaire 2019 fut une
année record pour le musée des 24 heures
du mans qui a vu défiler 124 mille cinq
cents visiteurs sur quatre mille mètres
carrés des miniatures des motos puis 140
véhicules dont 70 ayant couru la course
sont exposés pour marquer son
soixantième anniversaire le musée a mis
en place un tableau plutôt symbolique je
les appelais l'alpha et l'oméga parce
qu'en fait c'est un raccourci idéale à
la fois de l'histoire de l'automobile
parce que nous avons derrière nous la
plus ancienne voiture dans la collection
du musée donc un kart de dion bouton
c'est une machine à vapeur qui date de
1885 et à côté d'elle la porsche 919
abrite des 24 heures du mans 2016 donc
là on a un vrai choc on à 130 ans
d'histoire qui les sépare des
expositions temporaires prennent aussi
place au musée jusqu'en février 2022
c'est une exclusivité une collection
regroupant les automobiles toyota qui
ont participé aux 24 heures du mans
stabilisé par un vernis la ts 0,50 trône
fièrement au coeur de la collection
encore remarqué des traces de sa
bataille menée à huis clos l'an dernier
puisqu'elle est au musée depuis que nous
avons ouvert cette exposition il ya à
peine un mois elles rencontrent enfin
les fans et les passionnés des 24 heures
du mans il ya déjà plus de vingt mille
personnes qui ont pu lui rendre un
hommage qu'il n'avait pas pu lui rendre
et bien pendant l'édition des 24 heures
du mans 2020 pour le centenaire des 24
heures du mans en 2023 le musée en lien
avec l'automobile club de l'ouest se
prépare à une nouvelle exposition de
marque pour rendre hommage dignement à
la mythique course d'endurance
voilà sans transition un reportage qui
me tient particulièrement à coeur
maintenant le portrait d'un boxeur il
est monégasque il s'appelle hugo
mikheïev et une fois n'est pas coutume
il n'est pas passionné de vitesse ni de
course automobile en étant monégasques
n'ont eu beau gosse dans la catégorie
des super légers il vient de passer
professionnel
bravo à lui il s'est entraîné aux îles
canaries car il disputait vendredi son
premier combat chez les pros en
ouverture du gala qui a vu tony yoka
défendre sa ceinture européenne poids
lourd face aux croates
pitard millas une rencontre que n'a pas
raté nos confrères et partenaires sur
place de monaco info
devenu le premier boxeur professionnel
monégasques ont signant cette année avec
la société américaine top rank hugo milk
élèves s'entraînent deux fois par jour
sur l'île de gran canaria en vue de son
premier combat professionnel
aujourd'hui on fait technique n en fait
pas de bourse donc c'est que de la
technique c'est que l'apprentissage du
cou on essaie de donner des séries de
travailler la vitesse la puissance les
déplacements en fait on s'est un peu
tous les fondamentaux de la boxe chaque
entraînement j'arrive à l'entraînement
j'ai l'impression que ce sont alors
décroché la lune à chaque entraînement
en fait c'est tout ce que j'ai toujours
voulu plus subtile ça arrive maintenant
évident il reste trois semaines
d'entraînement et je ça commence il est
entraîné par carlos for men tôt mais
aussi suivi de près par son préparateur
physique thomas croteau qui n'est autre
que son meilleur ami d'enfance tout est
fait pour être prêt le jour du combat en
fait tous en fonction du combat qui
arrive en différentes semaine
d'entraînement donc on a plusieurs blocs
de trois semaines et là on est sur le
dernier bloc qu'on appelle l'affûtage du
haut de ses 1 m 80 il combattra dans la
catégorie des super légers moins de 63,5
kg en encadrement du combat opposant
tony yoka et peeters millas diffusée en
direct sur canal + le 10 septembre
prochain
voilà je vous le disais dans les titres
j'ai eu la chance de connaître de
pouvoir aussi tourné avec jean paul
belmondo
auquel la france a rendu hommage à
travers cet hommage qui a été réalisé
jeudi dernier aux invalides par le
président de la république et moi je
voudrais retenir le jean paul cette
petite interview qu'il m'avait donné
pour me parler d'une des choses qui lui
était le plus sacré sa famille et
notamment son fils paul belmondo dont il
m'a parlé en exclusivité écouter ce
témoignage de jean paul belmondo
mais il qu'ils aient passé plusieurs
étés un pays si vous alors
la caméra et appareil
toute ma vie je n'ai entendu quasiment
que des gens toujours me complimenter de
mon père c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois
il venait me disent à tel point il
aimait mon père ou comment il avait vécu
avec mon père comment il avait grandi
avec mon père et c'est vrai que que
cette génération qui la même génération
que la mienne
en fait ont grandi avec lui voilà merci
jean paul belmondo de nous avoir fait
rêver c'est la fin de ce dont j'étais
des territoires merci de l'avoir suivi
sur nos chaînes locales de la tnt et sur
tv5 monde on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un tour complet de
l'actualité de nos territoires au revoir
à tous et bon courage
[Musique]